si angela además alex sánchez que nos
acompaña aquí esta mañana también fue
testigo de cómo cayeron esas torres
gemelas y dos días después a pesar del
impacto emocional que eso puede suponer
vino aquí a ayudar en estas tareas de
limpieza durante al menos seis meses
álex si pude presenciar
horroroso día del 11 de septiembre como
un niño aquí no me preguntaba que como
yo podía servir a mi ciudad
en los momentos más oscuros
en nuestra república y tuve estuve la
virtud y la dicha
una llamada de mi supervisor y decir me
equivoqué del tarea de recuperación en
las 10 para mí fue como ganando en la
lotería para decir la verdad
usted está trabajando en esas labores de
limpieza durante seis meses en qué
condiciones de seguridad de presión
y empezamos a trabajar
el 13 de septiembre
equipo se configuraba de dos personas si
yo saco dos mis manos delante de mí yo
no podía ver mi hermano de la cantidad
de polvo que había tenido que usar poco
un live para
utilizar la ubicación donde estaba era
alguien que iván canca por el previsto
pero yo experimenté algo que fue alguien
que me conmovió de por vida después en
el nivel de hermandad que existía cuando
yo crucé las barricadas las nuestras
tías creadas y éstas es económicos
nuestro país viene viene viviendo buenas
epidemias gracias en más de doscientos
cuarenta y pico de años tiene un nivel
de hermandad me entristece porque
tenemos que ver lo peor para para reunir
no descrita almoneda está listo en este
momento las medidas de protección con
las que usted está trabajando en estas
labores de limpieza son una alguna
mascarilla alguna ropa especial como
trabajaba cada día tenían el equipo
adecuado que amerita
trabajo de
esta comisión tiene una mascarilla que
era un filtro de café eso es un material
de las causas cuales miles y miles de
personas estamos enfermos por la
exposición
hiroshima y nagasaki hemos visto un
nivel de contaminación tan alto como el
que en el perdón pudimos
y apreciar aquí en la solución
me gustó cuando llegaba a su casa se
encontraba bien durante esos seis meses
que estuvo trabajando no tuvo ningún
problema que indicara que más tarde
podría provocarle esta labor que usted
estaba haciendo de ayuda enfermedades
como las que tiene hoy si había bien
señales pero en mi muy fácil de querer
levantar a nuestra ciudad
nación en la cta nuestra economía y en
nuestra soberanía
ponía todo es atrás la primera semana
tuvo mucha dificultad
con la garganta
muchas lágrimas tupido todo el tiempo
normal y podría luego
[Música]
cuando yo la senadora giuliana carácter
hillary clinton hizo un servicio público
para que las personas que estuvieron
allí que fueran al monte sinaí asociar a
una especie de chequeo médico no escrito
y cuando uno abre una puerta que viene
y estoy
luego dure
16 años caminando los pasillos de
congreso valen hasta la ley esa droga
la barca
mil millones de dólares para tratamiento
médico gratuita y compensación monetaria
esté en ese momento después de seis
meses limpiando al cabo de unos meses se
da cuenta de que empiezan a provocarle
una serie de enfermedades que están
relacionadas con la limpieza de los
escombros del 11 cuáles son esas
enfermedades
el parejo de asma económicas tengo
cicatrices en los pulmones la misma
contaminación que dirigimos a la parte
de alta respiratoria pero también nos ha
afectado la vía gástrica
la vida
enfermedades la cual me
vine a tener una vida normal
este es el camino
en el estado de servirle a una comunidad
afligida por la contaminación denuncia
en septiembre y ha dado esa segunda a
muchos de mis compañeros son fallecidos
hay 20 colombianos que han fallecido por
la contaminación
solamente
estamos trabajando en una legislación
las cuales hoy en día son buenas porque
después de 20 años estamos trabajando
para legalizar a los vídeos de
publicados
que también al igual que nosotros dieron
el todo por el todo con nuestro país
esta legislación fue introducida en el
2017 pues yo sé probable quien fue
reemplazado por alessandro caso el corte
hoy en día un mensaje especial es para
alexandra ocasio por texto adriano
españa y media de las podéis trabajar en
una legislación la cual podemos
legalizar a 2008
dos mil personas que todavía están
indocumentadas a pesar de que han pasado
veinte años pero es que además aleix han
muerto más personas por las
consecuencias
de esa nube tóxica de aquel día que el
mismo día que cayeron las torres gemelas
hay casi cuatro mil personas que han
fallecido ya por las enfermedades
relacionadas con esa nube tóxica y esos
materiales cancerígenos que desplegó
sake que extendieron las torres gemelas
cuando se desplegaron mereció la pena
venir aquí a ayudar a estas labores a
cambio de estar estos 20 años luchando
contra tantas enfermedades se arrepiente
este nuevo momento
si yo tendría que hacerlo de nuevo yo lo
haría de nuevo
[Música]
serviré a mi país
la misión ha sido mejor que la vida
aparte de ser padre yo me siento muy
orgulloso no sólo de venir aquí pero de
trabajar seis años en el congreso a
favor de los senos
ah
a las gracias porque entiendo que no
debe ser nada fácil estar aquí con
nosotros porque hay otras heridas que
esas también son difíciles de sanar no
se ven físicamente y es ese impacto
psicológico con el que ustedes han
tenido que salir adelante todos estos
años lo desee supongo que el recuerdo el
presente your baile
pero él
unos documentos que estaban clasificados
en clásicos esos tienen mucho manual
para nuestro equipo y queremos agradecer
al presidente pues su labor como primer
mandatario de la democracia
muchas gracias
que esperan encontrar en esos documentos
que como decía hace pocos días el
presidente yo byron desclasificó de esa
investigación que había hecho el fbi y
sobre los autores del atentado del 11-s
haciendo política llevo 33 años
políticas el mismo sentido de no querer
azúcar a la población y decir que el
área no estaba contaminada era era para
remarcar nuestra economía pero hay
muchas cosas ocultas que estos
documentos desclasificados van a llevar
a la ley necesitamos sanar general y
está muy sana
horrible el fatídico día que todavía al
día a día vive con nosotros preguntamos
a nada necesitamos documentar a un
indocumentado en el camino que la verdad
salga a la luz y que esté esto que
sucedió no vuelva a suceder de nuevo en
nuestro país es muy difícil sanar a los
vamos a tirarnos un poquito hacia la
cámara para que los espectadores puedan
verle también es muy difícil sanar
cuando el recuerdo está tan vivo por
todo lo que acaba de comentar usted pero
también porque después de 20 años
todavía hay mil ciento seis cadáveres
sin nombre sin identificar todavía se
sigue trabajando en esas labores de
identificación así es muy difícil cerrar
estas heridas entiendo y su música que
dice que van a permanecer de por vida
sin lugar a dudas
pero tenemos que hacer todo lo
lo que amerita de nuestro gobierno
federal para poder llevar su solución y
llevar cerrar este capítulo de este
horroroso capítulo de nuestra historia
como se publica estamos vigentes el
terrorismo está vigente lo que está
sucediendo en afganistán y países como
rusia y china- patrocinando países
autoritarios abre la puerta para que
tengamos que seguir vigilantes en contra
el terror como dt de escribirte arroz es
pánico no sabes seguirá en la hacienda a
la derecha hacia atrás
tenemos que ser colectivo como país para
combatir del creador después de 20 años
esos recuerdos siguen despertando
todavía a día de hoy ese terror yo yo
vivo en la capital del mundo cada vez
que yo oigo un camión de bomberos una
ambulancia cuando veo un avión volando
bajo algo que se me sudan las manos de
enfermedad postraumático es muy difícil
de sanar pero si estamos trabajando y
darle las gracias a los programas
federales médicos que han estado ahí de
energía para nosotros este es el único
programa federal que le da a
tratamientos médicos gratuitos de
indocumentados gracias a un servidor y a
la delegación congresista
pero todavía tiene únicas embargo juanes
supongo que no ha sido fácil para usted
estos 20 años pero tampoco para sus
familiares porque al final ellos también
han vivido con usted todo este proceso y
tampoco debió ser nada fácil
para mi familia ha sido algo que ha sido
muy difícil madre también estuvo
en las acciones de limpieza ha sido
operada cuatro veces yo soy viudo yo
tengo yo soy padre soltero mi hijo está
caminando conmigo a los pasillos de
pobreza desde la piel de edad de cuatro
años hoy en día fue presidente de la
facultad de de su escuela que decir que
a esa escuela este ese liderazgo que
mengua pecando que son cosas buenas que
han llegado a mi edad pero también he
sido víctima de no poder ir a la
graduación de mil eventos sumamente
importante pues en enfermedad que
padecen muchas familias también han
denunciado que sus propios perdón a
muchas personas que estuvieron
trabajando en esas labores de limpieza
también han denunciado que sus propios
familiares tienen a día de hoy
enfermedades por ese polvo tóxico que
desprendía incluso la ropa que ustedes
llevaban cuando volvían de trabajar no
sé si en su caso se dice que las
personas mayores
saben mi abuela la madre de ningún modo
llegado
donde yo ponía las ropas y ella con
guantes y todo la llevaba especialmente
al sótano y la lavaba individualmente le
agradezco mucho a la sabiduría de
nuestros mayores porque sabes que saben
más que nosotros tienen muchos más
experiencias pero sí he visto casos de
que la ropa que se trajo a casa con
botellas anteriores ni en que dos imán y
nagasaki hemos visto este tipo de
contaminación una contaminación que
conocemos después después de unos años
en ese momento nadie sabía nada acerca
de esto supongo que también lo el
objetivo en ese momento era limpiar los
escombros lo antes posible pero ustedes
no tenían ningunos equipos sanitarios
cerca que les pudieran indicar cómo
llevar a cabo estas tareas de la manera
más segura posible no había ningún tipo
de entrenamiento por parte del gobierno
el gobierno federal si tenían
entrenamiento pero no tenía interior el
factor de no
y aterrorizar a la población y al sector
este es el sector más afluente desde yo
diría del mundo el distrito financiero
las personas que viven por aquí son las
personas más terminéis que
económicamente vivimos mismos estos
grupos de personas salen de la zona cero
por el mismo factor de miedo
dos días después era que yo estaba
trabajando aquí y en cuatro ocasiones
hubieron vacaciones de bombas porque en
la incertidumbre todavía arrastraba día
después
el terror el terror es algo que
terminación al y eso se puede sanar a
través de política exterior que
convengan a todos los son sólo a un
grupo
mínimamente esta muñeca es la madre de
todas las cintas queremos utilizarla
para racionar tanto lo que es el terror
erradicar el hambre las enfermedades que
existen mundiales no podemos ser como
seres muebles